خمس سنوات جديده في سده الرئاسه التركيه
وتحديات عده امام الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
على الصعيدين الداخلي والخارجي تحديات
ثلاثه هي الابرز وكانت مسيطره على المشهد
الانتخابي وهي الازمه الاقتصاديه قضيه
اللاجئين وعلاقه تركيا مع الغرب الاقتصاد
التركي يمر بمرحله حرجه مع وصول معدل
التضخم رسميا الى نحو 44% مع تشكيك البعض
بان معدل التضخم اعلى بكثير كما ادت
سياسات غير التقليديه التي دعا اليها
اردوغان الى هبوط قيمه الليره التركيه 80%
على مدى خمس سنوات ماضيه وانهيار ثقه
الاتراك في عملتهم ايضا في الشان الداخلي
يبقى تحدي اللاجئين امام اردوغان مثلا
ونتحدث هنا عن ثلاثه ملايين و400 الف لاجئ
سوري اضافه لمئات الالاف من الافغان
والايرانيين والعراقيين اردوغان تعاهد في
خطاب النصر بضمان مليون لاجئ سوري لبلادهم
في غضون سنوات قليله من خلال مشروع سكني
جديد يتم انشاؤه في شمال سوريا ايضا يعمل
اردوغان على حل الخلافات مع الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد ما يزيد من احتمال حدوث تقارب
ربما يساعد تركيا على تخفيف ازمه اللجوء
خارجيا يدعو اردوغان الى ان تتبنى تركيا
تحالفات متعدده الاطراف كما انه يعرض لعب
دوري الوسيط في الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
تركيا اتبعت سياسه منفتحه على الصين
وروسيا على حساب حلفاء انقره الغربيين
التقليديين وعلى سبيل المثال اشترت نظام
الدفاع الجوي الروسي اس 400 كما فتحت في
مرحله ما قبل الانتخابات محطه طاقه نوويه
روسيه صنع هي الاولى من نوعها في تركيا
غربا لا تشير المعطيات بحسب محللين الى اي
تغير في علاقات تركيا مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
في الفتره المقبله كما ان التشنج سيد
الموقف في النيتو هناك خبر جديد اطلعكم
عليه بعد قليل مع عدم موافقه تركيا على ضم
السويد للحلف وهو الامر الذي يشكل اولويه
رئيسيه لواشنطن والغرب بانتظار ما سيبدر
عن اردوغان في ولايته الثالثه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات